okay move out
Turo hello I'm lieutenant Jim joy Ella
your host on this issue of your army
reports your army is making news all
over the world Alaska from a military
parade in Seoul Korea to combat action
in Vietnam our program begins in the
United States Alaska we visit soldier is
undergoing sky high mountaineer training
next on to Asia and a story of the
embarkation of Republic of Korea
soldiers arrive in the combat zone and
finally a ride on a river patrol boat
and an account of a typical patrol
action including the rescue of a downed
helicopter
some time ago Hurricane Betsy swept
inland over southern Louisiana and sank
a barge loaded with liquid chlorine in
the Mississippi River near Baton Rouge
Army engineers working with civilian
contractors were immediately assigned to
remove a dangerous threat to the station
to people living in the area the
engineer aggressive map for which marked
the exact spot where the barge and shaft
are
the divers found the chlorine tanks 200
feet from the bank in 60 feet of water
next the engineers prepared a detailed
survey of mountain guards and the
surrounding river bottom in order to
determine the safest topic civilian
contractor is supervised and assisted by
the Corps of Engineers use their skill
and ingenuity to devise a framework for
the hazardous operation a barge morning
to collect Eric when a combined with the
fact that they obtain hundred tons was
brought back
the gold submerged weight of the barge
tanks and cargo was 389 tonnes aerial
patrols kept a strict surveillance of
the area experts in heaven for rain work
closely with the engineers throughout
the operation to ensure maximum safety
as the cranes lifted the submerged load
sensitive test equipment recorded any
air contamination on the barge for grant
efficiently defects part to inspect the
condition of a farming tank and piping
and farm them condemned as a further
precaution the barge and tanks were
hosed down for thorough decontamination
a potential disaster was averted a
successful demonstration of effective
civilian and military teamwork
the re plans is undergoing extensive
development tests at the White Sands
proving ground in New Mexico
is being developed to replace beyond the
comic-con and possibly the little guy
the Lance is designed to complement
division tube artillery the missile
launcher can be self propelled by
mounting on a track vehicle
the Lancia Liza's a special control
system for pinpoint accuracy
it is the first armored missile designed
to use prepackaged storable liquid
propellants the Lance has been developed
for the army Missile Command by civilian
contractors
the crew of specialists mr. Biden lay
the necessary cables and prepare for
firing
as a white sands missle business reign
as the army welcome to position to an
ever growing arsenal of aggression
deeper
from a position of safety the unit
commander makes a final check to ensure
all is ready and hence the order
that's my raincatcher says prove the
Lance's future is bright
army troops training in Alaska are
learning to be at home in the
mountainous terrain as neighboring
thousand feet above sea level
these villagers are gaining an honest
respect for danger and the steel
incompetence of expert Mountaineer
mr. annotate army mountain and Ranger
training centre is located near Fort
Richardson in a jagged mountain rape
over up the massive block George Blake
from here men of Company C 4th battalion
23rd Infantry of the 172nd Infantry
Brigade are broadening the scope their
combat capabilities for trainings in
America
each day the troops are learning binding
an extra 15 feet on their own rock faces
to fight song step but they're elected
in the process the hard way
the craft of mountaineering requires
more than brute strength and share
personal educated and pioneering
the training ranges from demonstrations
of know-how and equipment to do it
yourself
mountain goat exercises the occupational
hazards are awesome
you
after two weeks of such training the
troops rotate with others of the command
however enable the army freightin bans
imposed it effectively on every type of
terrain
and Australia these soldiers can already
point with pride to their contributions
toward victory in Vietnam
effective Armed Forces Day parade in
Seoul Sunday the 17th anniversary of the
Republic of Korea spectators lined the
route of March as representatives of the
Armed Forces pass in review where they
will embark on United States Navy ships
to South Vietnam
these men are volunteers who will
represent their proud country in the
fight for freedom
highly praying ring the ring fits as
well we should
meanwhile crowds packed Seoul City
Airport to give the grandest send-off in
history to elements of the division who
are leaving for Vietnam by hair the
presence of this callous country go with
their men as they leave to serve the
cause of freedom in another land
in all 15,000 Republic of Korea troops
have volunteered for duty in Vietnam in
sending two regiments from the tiger
division once in Vietnam the Tigers are
quick to kill their claws as they stop
an elusive enemy forward observation
verifies an enemy held strong point
which is soon brought under fire
then the troops move up through
difficult terrain always alert for signs
or sounds of the Vietcong
they move cautiously forward one squad
at a time
demonstrate the results of intensive
combat spring together
Allied troops they push forward toward
victory on the Vietnam fight
the first Battalion Royal Australian
regiment arise by a Black Hawk in Saigon
day to placate with this volunteer unit
is 1 mm Nam for duty with the Allied
forces
the troops debarked the carrier down
gangplank sharing their personal gear
into amphibious craft which swiftly from
president to the winning LSP
then they are heated to the beach
is the defense of strategic Erbil
however the Royal Australian regiment is
a first-class fighting outfit well able
to handle any assignment given them at
their base past the airfield of benoit
the Aussies join American soldiers in
the internationally popular caltime
afterwards the men get rapidly to work
setting up base communications then some
routine items can be taken care of and
before combat another type of shooting
the Aussies are well trained in the art
of camouflage and the men from Down
Under
know how to handle the tools of modern
warfare
and later on a patrol around their
defense perimeter facing a real but well
hidden enemy the royal family in Vietnam
contributing destroyed of the free world
the successful waging of the war in
Vietnam takes many forms sometimes very
little happens that would make a
military communication involved in a
helicopter rescue mission
with good roads at a premium in Vietnam
rivers serve as vital arteries of
transport and Commerce in order to both
control and newspapermen remote control
or a useful feature of these river
traffic
Vietnamese naval personnel working with
the guidance of their American naval
military advisors are keeping traffic
moving and are constantly on the alert
for the Vietcong one such unit is the
22nd River for these military units
operating on shore
in this case a request has been received
to transfer gone back to the bank after
complete admission and calm presence is
verified on the opposite bank of the
river so the Vietnamese commander calls
for covering fire during the troop
withdrawal operation
the first door is raped by the kingdom
or the garage and protection the man
about to come aboard
a civil war ship this Vietnamese naval
crab proves its work almost hidden by
the heavy jungle foliage the troops
nimbly come aboard the waiting control
the completion of another successful
operation the ground forces are returned
safely to their base courtesy of the
22nd river assault group of the
Vietnamese Navy
survey men of the city Military Police
Company after a fall scepter job
detachment and Alisha's as well as
rifles
since its arrival in August of 1965 the
unit has provided security for radar
installations and munition sights
communication centers and other
vulnerable areas about the vast airbase
the actual and psychological advantage
of The Chronicle far has already proved
too great in opposing Vietcong
infiltration and attack each of the
four-legged guards is a one-man goal as
in the case of spoken of Zion 2tsp win
our darkness from pointing again for
April PFC Barnett and since 2010 and
their relationship is reformed
I'm important in a place where friend
and foe are difficult to determine a
sentry dog has learned to respond
immediately to voice commands and
gestures of his handler situated no TP
are real
after a rest period toward late
afternoon another training session and
we begin their night special all the
teams are transported to ensure the
sound sleep recovers and the security of
verifying a combat camber moon stands it
film coverage of typical Vietnam for
full action of an element of the 1st
Infantry Division at opening the pelvis
description of the action as we witness
and photograph it the company is
participating in a regimental pride
operation in one of the proudest
periodically during the operation
members of the big red zone we face
cypress fire from the Vietcong and
returning fire
by the time I reach the area most of the
shooting is over because the Vietcong
have been driven from their positions
and have melted into the surrounding
jungle
this company are engaged in a road
during project where the Vietcong have
ambushed an American convoy the night
before the purpose of the sweep is to
clear the road and surrounding villages
of any enemies fills in the area
however this time band Norman
by end of the stroke
return for support anyways a
search-and-destroy operation in a
different part of the problem
during combat by units of the 1st
Cavalry Division airmobile on troop
supply helicopter of uh-1d class is
disabled a radio message relay resonance
secured position establishing perimeter
defenses against attack the helicopter
crew works rapidly to prepare their down
craft for air rescue
recovering this we're already airborne
and sitting on the down burn the
helicopter is to be airlifted by the
all-purpose ch-47 or Chinook the us crew
directs the Chinook pilot into position
as the supporting player will be
repaired to fly again the Vietnam got a
number of rescue craft participate so
that everything moves the downed
helicopter back for repairs and to
continuing their assigned mission
men and machines coordinates to salvage
valuable aircraft
once more the Army's new mobility proves
it felt on the battleground
you